[Music]
oh stop it
okay
Two Bros who are solid muscle are
chatting about Jesse's hustle they
discuss their role in the false flag
orchestrated so Jesse Smollett could
brag Bola and Ola osadario the Nigerian
Hans in France are finally breaking
their Silence about their involvement in
the infamous Justice Smollett hoax a
hoax that was so convincing it fooled
these Brilliant Minds
I don't like that it's being put out
there in the media that this is a
possible hate crime for a lot of
questions in this case but I know Jesse
smallett is a really really good guy I
just want Justice to be served in this
case and the media has really cast so
much doubt on his story which I find so
personally offensive he's given a
detailed account an account that Chicago
Police have said has been consistent he
hasn't changed the story they also said
it's credible police have said that and
also that he has been very Cooperative
they should all be fired
up
for the new exclusive show on Fox Nation
no it's not a casino
the Nigerian Brothers open up about that
fateful night on Fox Nation in the in
when actor Justin smilette claimed he
was the victim of a white supremacist
anti-gay anti-black hate crime he hired
two black guys to carry out the hoax
proving he truly believes in equity
smilette claimed the brothers were white
white supremacists who poured bleach on
him and tied a noose around his neck all
while yelling he was in Maga country why
are we retelling this entire story I
don't know
because as we all know Chicago is a
hotbed of right-wing activism here's
their head of the KKK
but like a wool thong in the washing
machine it quickly unraveled
as you know smilet orchestrated it all
even paying the brothers by check to be
in on the whole thing wait until we tell
the whole story hit it flying back from
Nigeria we were expecting our other 500
check I felt like I was just gonna get
back to business head back started doing
auditions continue working out and
living my great life I had a whole
different feeling I felt like the police
was waiting for me the Customs agent was
checking everyone's passport two big ass
police officer came up I went with them
I was like damn it's over with they got
me so well they didn't give smaletta
racist beating he craved they did show
him the importance of something much
more valuable and that is acting lessons
the next time smell like Cass a hate
crime he should do a one-man show and
just punch himself in the face Lord were
you ever just for even a moment or did
you were you like all of us that like
didn't want to say anything because we
knew it was fake but we didn't want to
be first we all have jobs okay all right
all right and we got to be easy on this
I mean I could have said it but you
couldn't say it yes you know
look there's two things right here first
of all
they're lying the the Chicago Police
knew it was the setup the entire time it
was they were just waiting for him to
bury himself right that's the first
thing but number two he scripted this
like a movie yes that's why he doesn't
have a job I mean it doesn't make sense
at all but I also think this is this
tells you about wokeness and the racial
grievance politics of things is that he
uses as a negotiator the plan was to use
this as a negotiation to get more money
and Empire that that was it wasn't look
let me get more people to follow me it
wasn't let me find another movie to get
started where I can raise my star power
it was let me put the country pitted
against each other and let me be the
victim and then I'll get more money I
mean that is just sick it is I mean it
is mind-blowing Joe that he's out of
jail I mean he could have started a race
war
uh you know that's not how you get
acting work that's the trouble with
acting is that anybody can do it you
know like look you could cast me as a
spy yeah here's me as a spy
I'm not a spy actually
excellent you need you need an angle
Craig that's why I say um I'm a victim
of bullying like back in an elementary
school sometimes even the girls would
would beat me up just because I tried to
take their lunch money
[Laughter]
such an interesting
though you would watch the hell the hell
out of this as a reality show why are
they in Hall why aren't they getting a
reality TV show
I did watch some of it my favorite part
was when they said when he started
denying that this is what happened
they're like oh we just now we just
started seeing this different side of
him
that's the side he showed you like he
you know they said they felt betrayed
but in order to be betrayed I feel like
you have to trust somebody and maybe
don't trust the guy that's approaching
you to orchestrate a multi-layered hate
crime hoax yeah you know because if ever
someone's like mean to everyone but you
you're not special it's just not your
turn yet you know uh to defend him Sarah
you could say that this kind of hate
crime hoax was incentivized by a climate
that rewards people for doing it he just
saw the writing on the wall and said you
know what the pursuit of happiness now
includes hoaxes yeah okay and back to
Kamala who was one of the first who was
sympathetic and defending of the lies
when Jesse cried wolf it was Kamala here
that's true she saw they so wanted to
believe that this was true because yes
it was all about division but it also
tells you what they think of the country
right that this could be possible I mean
none of it made sense to begin with with
all of us we're sitting there just
waiting for the moment to implode but no
one could say anything you know what and
that's why you got to give credit to the
Chicago reporters the local reporters
who were getting the abuse from
everybody for for dogging for dog and
Reporting and you know they they they
were right all along and people they had
to they had to stick to it even though
nobody else would that was amazing hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else